mieux comprendre les missions de la
caisse d'allocations familiales des
yvelines afin de mieux aider la
population
voilà l'objectif de ces échanges entre
sept députés yvelinois issus de la
majorité et l'équipe dirigeante
c'est marquant en ce début d'année la
hausse du nombre de bénéficiaires de la
prime d'activité l'occasion de faire le
point sur sa mise en place dans notre
département nous avions anticipé
l'organisation avec à dispositif
d'accueil dédié en fait aux nouveaux
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité
avec une organisation également de back
office dédiées pour absorber le pic de
charge
donc c'est vrai que globalement malgré
le chiffre donc l'augmentation
importante de bénéficiaires de cette
prime consécutive aux annonces
gouvernementales
on a été globalement en capacité
d'absorber le choc de la réforme au 31
décembre 2018 dans les yvelines ont
compté plus de 235 me la locataire parmi
les sujets abordés lors de cette matinée
le recouvrement des pensions
alimentaires ou encore l'accompagnement
des bénéficiaires
objectif aller encore plus loin en
matière d'accès au droit
on a vraiment besoin qui beaucoup plus
d'interconnexions pour ne pas dupliquer
les choses mais aussi pour que les
informations qui parviennent alain
parviennent également à tous les autres
pour que
on n'est pas de encore une fois de trous
dans la raquette une rencontre dans le
cadre de la stratégie de lutte contre la
pauvreté voulue par le gouvernement dès
2020 par exemple le numéro pour joindre
la caf ne sera plus surtaxé